you had this very successful pro racing
career and then you suffered this
terrible accident what exactly happened
big jump sperms really fast loud yeah
just trying to make up some time and got
crossed up and got pitched off the
machine landed with all my weight on my
left leg and my knee hyper-extended 180
degrees actually the point where I
kicked myself in the chin it went it
went the wrong way oh my god that's just
yeah yes so did you think at that moment
I mean you obviously it must be a
horrifying pain where your thoughts
okay this they can they can fix this
yeah I mean with with my line of work
racing snowmobiles and dirt bikes
injuries are know fairly common right
and they've always been able to bolt me
back together one way or another and so
this time I knew it was bad compound
fracture and took me off to the hospital
and over the course of three days really
ran into some complications with nerve
damage and and and circulation and ended
up getting really sick
kidneys shutting down and basically I
was the point where the only way to save
my life was to amputate my leg oh my god
okay
and uh you know yeah to take that as a
professional athlete that was a pretty
hard hit I I can imagine I mean anybody
in any circumstances no matter what they
do going through that would be
horrifying you a lot of people would at
that point say okay my career in sports
is over not you you decided I'm going to
go about and they probably told you here
are your options for prosthetic leg you
weren't satisfied with what they had
yeah I it was it was really quick
turnaround once once the amputation
happened was in the hospital for
thirteen days and then five and a half
weeks later I got on my first prosthesis
which was really quick compared to most
and yeah it was crazy I I watched TV and
saw some special equipment and so I was
somewhat familiar with it but I got the
first leg and it was it was a basic
mechanical hinge and you got to swing it
out in front up put your weight on it
and then you step again and it kind of
swings under yeah but the problem is is
when when I kick a little pebble in
front of me or
the curb and go to put my weight on it
and it's not there and I just yeah I
just right so now it's right on my face
obviously not satisfied with what was
out there no not gonna work for jump in
the dirt biker right no bill at all you
decided which is this is the part that I
find incredibly fascinating I'll build
my own yeah i'm i think mechanically I'm
a problem-solver and young age I was
always really interested in how things
work did I mechanically and always in
the garage fixing things and I'm like
what what better project then building
your own leg and motivated very very
motivated there's amazing thing you
built you built you built the leg in one
week and what fascinated me is I love I
like bicycling and I like mountain
biking you know taking a bicycle up in
the mountains and and you use mountain
bike parts yeah yeah it's you know I I
drew on the design for about a month and
then once I had everything just right
went to the shop and started cutting
metal and a week later I had the first
prototype and I knew I wanted to utilize
this mountain bike shop it's a it's a
Fox float or DHA DHX air shock uses
compressed air as a spring rate so which
is really light and adjustable and for
all the different activities you can
really fine-tune it and you know I kind
of thought it not so much as as an E but
as a suspension component for for my leg
unbelievable and we have one we have one
right here do you want to show us how it
works now what's interesting is I pick
this up and it feels heavy to me but
it's actually lighter than the
corresponding part of you of the human
leg is that right yeah yeah it's it's
about half the weight of the leg that
they took off right it definitely feels
a lot heavier cuz it's it's it's hanging
off you but it yeah lighter the better
for sure we've got a shock right here in
the knee yeah those are the same that's
the same shocks that I use on my bike
and you can what is amazing is you can
adjust you can adjust the if you're
going downhill or going up here yeah
adjust how much to spend
yeah we've got compression rebound we
got a lockout here air pressure
adjustment then also the foot has the
Versa foot also has one too
yeah in it this this is used for sport
and not not the best for walking and
I've got some other options for walking
but man when you really want to get
after it and and hit some big jumps this
is the ticket yeah
and when did this become an infomercial